i
certainly working very hard
with a great team to give the best
blockchain
that one uh can demand and
enjoy and they said i really believe
that
there is going to be it's not a winner
takes them all so it's going to be
a few blockchains and each one is going
to have
its own brand and it's going to be
great at something and sometimes it's a
scalability sometimes
is uh easier views or sometimes is uh
thing
and and it's important to have a
dialogue between these things and
i'm sure and i'm working very hard to
make sure the underground is one of them
but i don't believe of it you know he's
even
desirable to have you know a winner and
takes all because
we need to express different things but
the important thing is going
to have enough interoperability of our
systems
so that you can transfer your assets
where you have the best tool to service
them whatever your needs are at the time
so there's a idea i don't know they call
themselves
bitcoin maximalists which is essentially
the bet that
uh the philosophy that bitcoin will
eat the world so you're talking about
it's good to have variety
their claim is it's good to have the
best technology
dominate the the medium of exchange the
the medium of
the store value the money the digi you
know the
the digital currency space what's your
sense
of the positives and the negatives of
that
so i feel people are smart and it's
going to be very hard
for anybody and to end a man a twin and
because
people want more and more things yeah
and
there is an italian saying that the
ghost as translates well i think
it goes the appetite grows while eating
okay
i think you don't understand what he
means yes so i say i'm not hungry
okay food let me try so we want more and
more and more
and when you find something like bitcoin
which are very
very good things to say but it does
something very well
but it's ecstatic i mean store
value yes i think it's a great like
you know it would be a sad world if the
world in which we are so anchoring down
some when defensive that we want to
store value and hide it on the mattress
i long for a world in which
is open people want to transact and
interact with which way
and therefore when you want to store
value
one perhaps one chain you want to have
the transaction maybe
is another i'm not saying that you know
uh
one chain cannot be stored of value of
everything but i really believe
i believe in the ingenuity of people any
in the
innovation that is intrinsic to the
human nature we want always different
things so how can it be something
invented
whatever it is decades ago is going to
fulfill the needs of our future
generations um
i'm not going to fulfill my needs let
alone
one of my kids or their kids
we are going to have a different world
and uh
things will evolve so you believe yeah
so you believe that
life intelligent life is ultimately
about adaptability
and evolving so static is uh
static loses in the end yes
you